there's such beautiful lighting and
cinematography in between us and
especially love the opening scenes that
you have around is in Nebraska yeah
Nebraska hmm so what were your
production days like what kind of camera
were you shooting with and how many
people were on your crew um we had a
first of all we had a wonderful
cinematographer Nancy Schreiber ASC and
she kicks it ASC it's funnier on paper
but she I got it I mean she you know and
her background is really on the gaffing
side so she likes her lights she made
the joke Thea just the other day I wish
she told me this when we started she's a
chic people say uh Nancy do you can you
use available light she says yeah any
light available she'll use you know I
was like how that explains it ska
cinematographer with a sense of humor oh
yeah yeah and I mean I always say like
you know I mean this is true with any
crew member but especially with your
cinematographer you know there can be
some great cinematographers who are real
pains in the ass to work with and
they're really nice people who maybe not
be so good but at least you can talk to
them work through it man nancy was was
great everything you know I mean I I got
along wonderfully well with her we were
a real team you know to this day still
are and and just got amazing beautiful
imagery out of it and she was teaching
at AFI at the time so she had a lot of
her students come and work on the film
and it was a great opportunity for them
but we had different camera operators
every day wait a couple guys Colby
Oliver one guy in particular one of her
students was on pretty much most of the
shoot but the second operator was
different every time because we're
shooting two cameras to reds and we
actually had a third red as a backup
which came from our investors in
Nebraska who are farmers but they had
their own red camera because crop
circles yeah yeah and well they even
nephews of filmmakers I say oh the
camera and so we had that as a backup
you know because these things go down so
we would use the body for at different
times um but uh so Nancy and I would be
at the two monitors and
and then have two different operators
and she was very good at sort of
managing how they would go so they
weren't shooting into each other barrel
of each other which was I was very
impressed with you know so we always had
great usable footage from both cameras
but i think the you know the challenge
because you know no matter how good
things are there are always challenges
was you know it took a long time to
light you know because it was largely an
inexperienced crew and nancy likes her
lights and there were a lot of them so
it took us a few days to kind of find a
rhythm where we could wear I think Nancy
and I together realized you know the big
lightning changes we're going to take a
long time we didn't want them to but
they did and that was frustrating for
the actions frustrating for me as a
director and it slowed down our days but
what didn't take a long time we're
camera changes so a change of a dolly
move or you know change of a you know if
you're using a zoom you to zoom in you
get a hold of you and you go from two
shot to one shot those kinds of little
changes are changing the focus mark you
know so those could be done you know
very quickly between takes and the
advantage of having rehearsed and having
great actors to begin with its
performance wise we are getting great
first takes you know first second takes
as far as I'm concerned performance wise
done we're good ready to move on now the
actors may want their own coverage and
close subs everyone left the close up
you know but so what we would do is once
we knew we have the performance in the
can we would say okay well then for
subsequent takes so come drives the
actors crazy a little bit because
they're like because Nancy's a real
Tweaker feel like we're up you know and
then sit back down with me but a lot of
times what we could do is Josh who's our
first AC on one of the cameras had a
remote control control for the red I
don't know what it's called but you know
control focus and zoom and everything
even sometimes during a take I would
whisper to him or nay I know Nancy would
whisper to me you know let's
let's nudge in a little bit let's do a
slow zoom here we did the fair number of
slow zooms it in the movie and and we
could do that you know without the
camera operators even knowing it in the
middle of a shot and and they'd be like
what oh those guys and but it was great
it was it was it was nice to be able to
do that and to have that option you know
part of it was that we shot on 4k and we
finished in 2k which I don't really know
what that means except for is bigger
than two and that's what counts because
what that meant was that I knew that in
post-production we would be we would
have the option to zoom in and basically
keep have enough resolution to do that
and we didn't realize I don't think we
realized until we were in to post really
far into it how far we could go that we
could go about a hundred and
seventy-five percent which is a lot
farther than we were originally told we
could do but what a meant it was if you
had a two-shot you could zoom into a
single if you had a four-shot you could
zoom into a two-shot in post-production
so for for any take we were shooting
with two cameras and two cameras meant
not just to take your not just to usable
takes but really for because you know
with zooming in and zooming out and post
you could really do a whole scene and
just one take and it takes a while to
kind of explain this to the actors and
really and again we didn't realize how
far we could take it until we really
started working with the colorist and
the you know the post-production people
but what it means you can get a lot of
coverage very quickly and again as long
as your actors are good and they're
doing the part and they're saying the
lines right which they were so so that
gave us a lot more opportunities in
post-production you know I mean there's
certain reasons you don't want to do
that but for the most part it gives you
a lot of options you know and then and
then as you mentioned I mean some of the
scenes are so emotional that you can't
do more than a couple takes it just
wears the actors at and so I sometimes
the actors would be like you know I
can't do any more
if I'm crying in this scenic route you
know or they lose their voice you know
and then as other times you're like oh
no I won't do it again I don't ya and so
you don't always know how many cakes
you're going to get sometimes but I mean
these actors they let it all out I mean
there's every actor in here crying at
one point or another we're all crying on
set you know so I mean these are tough
scenes to shoot and a lot of them are
long scenes and we've won seen it
towards the end of the movie it's
actually on paper it was a 19-page scene
and we tried to do it once all the way
through which is not even for those who
don't know it's like a 19-minute see you
know something that actually is probably
15 minutes but still it's a long seen a
lot of dialogue and we got through one
take all the way through and everyone
was like we can't do this again we you
know we have to break it up into
segments which we kind of knew we would
ultimately do but we wanted to do kind
of one dry run through and but I'll tell
you footage from that original take long
take is in the movie and a lot of it
because then then once we broke it up
then all of a sudden the cameras weren't
a little bit different so we use
coverage from that first take and it is
you get something fresh from it of
course the cameras were bumping into
actors I mean it was you know those
reasons you don't want to do a 90 minute
long take but and that was a handheld
seen you know there weren't there wasn't
there's not much hand held in the movie
but we kind of use it in very specific
places so you know what else how many
hours of footage did you get I don't
know I had countless hours countless a
lot and and how painful was it to cut
out certain scenes whether certain
scenes that you really just didn't want
to lose but you knew that maybe they
just it didn't work in terms there
aren't that many scenes like full scenes
that we cut out and you know I just put
the DVD together and so there are some
deleted scenes I oh yeah I guess we'd to
cut this it's more like little sections
you know a little you know line you know
this lines there chunks of scenes and
there's nothing I feel that bad about it
except this one scene that my wife and
three kids are in is kind of background
and but it just didn't quite work
editing and pacing wise and but it's on
the DVD extras so I'm like they can
watch that you know but otherwise the
bigger regrets are the scenes that we
didn't shoot so you know on a movie like
this you know when you say okay we're
going to make the day there's no coming
back to these locations you know so
there would be scenes that we would push
to the next day and the next day and
then you're gone from that location you
can't go back so there were whole scenes
that I didn't shoot that are in the
script I was just actually reading the
script again last night and I was like
oh yeah we didn't shoot that did we so
that you know then you're like okay am I
painting myself into a corner you know
so part of it becomes about scheduling
like you want to try to put the less
crucial scenes you know at the end of
the day but then sometimes it leads to
some really nice moments you know
there's one scene that as scripted
Cheryl goes upstairs and we had a we had
a steady count for the day specifically
to get the shot to get to get her coming
up the stairs down the hall closing the
baby's door and then turning back around
and we just didn't have the time to do
it and it was the end of the day it was
like 730 we have to be out by eight
o'clock and you got exactly 12 hours
with the actors got your turnaround time
if we back the next morning and so we
had to improvise you know I was killing
us but we had to improvise a shot with a
still with a camera on sticks from the
bottom of the stairs where we don't come
up with her she's basically we lose her
and then she comes in but because we
were kind of rushing to get that we only
have like two lights to use and it's as
beautiful silhouette echad at the top of
the balcony and it just ends one of our
favorite scenes you know mine and
Nancy's and Melissa the actress is in it
and so sometimes you you you get lucky
you know you're forced by circumstance
okay you have to cut this but what else
can we do there's a couple other scenes
specifically with Melissa and Julia that
for whatever reason we're always
scheduled at the end of the day and we
were rushing and we had to rush those
scenes so instead of these elaborate you
know to camera and let's do four takes
and tweak the lights and treat the
cameras were like we're doing a water
make it count and they were such
troopers about it you know the actresses
and and could pull them off because
again they have been rehearsing by
themselves a lot of these things and
there's and there's a couple of these
scenes in the kitchen two scenes in the
kitchen one with a baby the 1si in the
kitchen particularly that instead of
doing any camera movement we're just
racking from one to the other it's just
the AC doing this this this and it's a
beautiful scene it works perfectly you
you know I think we did like four or
five takes to get the marks right once
we got it we're like this is it it works
as a water let's make it work you know
let's make it work and it did and it
looks beautiful and it's and people
think I'm a genius for coming up fancy
you know but it's just because it was
the end of the day didn't have time for
a second camera what did you learn about
the time that it took to adjust the
lighting what were some of your regrets
or is it just there's there was well I
say I think you learn how to manage that
situation which is to say okay so we're
not going to worry about the lights
let's worry about the camera you know in
other words you figure out okay every
scene doesn't have to have complete
cross coverage of you know headshot
close up over the shoulder over this
over that because every time you do that
you have to change light so instead like
okay what can you shoot from kind of one
kind of proscenium without changing
lights but knowing that your next scene
is going to be this way you know so that
you know from the audience perspective
you you're not thinking oh this I'm just
watching you like a play with plenty of
this that feels like a play anyway but
but that it's because it's these overs
that
that really slow you down so this way
you just find ways of blocking the
actors and blocking that the camera
movement to kind of use the lights that
are there without having to completely
rely in the in the New York scenes we
were able to use China balls you know
for a lot of the lighting and that helps
speed things up in there I'm in the
world that likes to but that definitely
sped things up a little bit in there
you